there's the kind of power that comes
from having military advantages and
having a large army and weaponry and so
on and there's the kind of power that
comes from having moral authority and
having people invested in in your cause
people believing that you are
representative of somehow a better
future in some ways there's a tension
between those two kinds of ideals
they're people who point to you know the
United States having this sprawling
military Empire and bases all around the
world as the basis for American power
and there are people who look at this is
what kind of shooting people who look at
this as a example of a society
struggling could be democratic to
operate and organize itself as a
democracy at the beginning of his
presidency and then during the campaign
Barack Obama relied more on the latter
than the former now he famously when he
was campaigning for Senate seat in
Illinois talked about his opposition to
the Iraq war he did say he wasn't
opposed to all wars just dumb Wars and
he categorized this as a dumb war but
when he talked about the United States
what he really dwell don was the
strength of the US as an example which
was ironic that people been said that
you know the people accused him of not
thinking the United States was
exceptional or not embracing the
doctrine of American exceptionalism and
what he actually did was voice that
doctrine that had kind of separated it
from the chest thumping jingoistic
narcissism that we think of you know
exceptionalism as when we look at the
way his presidency has evolved it's been
a kind of complicated balance of that
moral authority and then the military
might and you saw that transition
immediately early in his presidency
when we used SEAL Team six to to take
out the individuals in Somalia on the
coast of Somalia who had kidnapped
Americans for some people seem
paradoxical so this person who had
talked about hope and change to kind of
use military might in that way they're
people who also thought that kind of
same idea about him and the approach
they took 22 nullifying the threat to
Osama bin Laden posed by flying into the
sovereign territory of another country
and using the military to to kill this
person and remove him there is in an
ideal world a way of you know using
power that does not entail the
oppression and exploitation of other
people i just don't know how we get to
that world and in the context of that I
don't know what I don't know what she
prescribed in place of that
[Music]